THAT HE WAS IN FACT ACTING ALONE
AS THE CITY REMAINS ON HIGH
ALERT TONIGHT.
SPEAK TO THANK YOU VERY MUCH.
WE ARE JUST GETTING NEW COMMENTS
FROM THE PRESIDENT OF THE
UNITED STATES, DONALD TRUMP,
KIMBERLY.
HE SAYS THIS.
AT TODAY'S TERROR SUSPECTS
ENTERED OUR COUNTRY THROUGH
EXTENDED FAMILY CHAIN MIGRATION.
WHICH IS INCOMPATIBLE WITH
NATIONAL SECURITY.
AND HE CALLS FOR CONGRESS TO END
THE DEATH PENALTY.
WHAT ARE YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> Kimberly: IT IS POWERFUL IN
TALKING ABOUT PREVIOUSLY SAYING
THAT HE WAS AGAINST CHAIN
MIGRATION.
ABLE TO COME IN FROM AN UNCLE,
THEN THREW HIS MOTHER AND BE
ABLE TO GET IN JUST PRIOR, A
COUPLE OF MONTHS PRIOR TO HIS
21ST BIRTHDAY.
AND IF HE HAD TURNED 21, HE
WOULD NOT HAVE BEEN ABLE TO.
PRESIDENT AND OTHERS ARE EAGER
TO CLOSE.
IN A SITUATION LIKE THIS WHERE
HE IS RADICALIZED ONLINE.
I THINK THAT THEY SHOULD MAKE
EVEN A LARGER PUSH TO SHUT DOWN
SOME OF THESE RADICALIZED SITES
THAT ARE REALLY HAVING SUCH A
DO HARM TO US.
AND IT JUST TAKES ONE PERSON
WITH A PIPE BOMB, SOMETHING LIKE
THAT.
HE WAS NOT VERY GOOD AT IT.
HE INJURED HIMSELF, NOT ENOUGH,
OBVIOUSLY PRETTY YOU SHOULD HAVE
IMPOSED THE DEATH PENALTY ON
HIMSELF RIGHT THEN AND THERE.
BUT THANK GOD MORE PEOPLE WERE
NOT INJURED OR HURT.
IT SHOWS YOU THE COMPLEXITY OF
THE PROBLEM IN COMBATING TERROR
IN HIGHLY DENSE OR URBAN AREAS
LIKE THIS AND CITIES WHERE YOU
HAVE A LARGE OPERATION --
HARM IN TERMS OF FATALITIES AND
ET CETERA, BECAUSE WE LIVE IN
SUCH A DENSELY COMPACT
COMMUNITIES.
>> Jesse: SPORTS AUTHORITY,
THE LARGEST BUS TERMINAL IN THE
UNITED STATES.
WE HEARD FROM PRESIDENT TRUMP,
AND ALSO FROM OPENER CUOMO AND
MAYOR de BLASIO, HOW DO YOU
THINK THEY HANDLED THE INCIDENT
TODAY?
>> Dana: WE WILL HEAR ABOUT
THE SPORTS AUTHORITY POLICE
OFFICERS THEY WERE RIGHT ON THE
SCENE IMMEDIATELY.
THANKFULLY THERE WERE ALL THE
ONLY FIVE INJURIES WHICH IS
CONSISTENT WITH THIS TYPE OF
THING.
BUT I THINK ONE OF THE THINGS TO
POINT OUT, REMEMBER THE TRUCK
ATTACK A MONTH AGO.
ANYTIME YOU HAVE ONE OF THESE
CAN BE THIS MINOR EVENT,
RELATIVELY MINOR FOR --
THANKFULLY NO OTHER CASUALTIES.
BUT WE ARE SPENDING A LOT TO
TRAIN OUR EMERGENCY MEDICAL
PERSONNEL, OUR LAW ENFORCEMENT,
OUR INTELLIGENCE.
WE HAVE MADE A REALLY BIG
COMMITMENT.
AND GREG IS GOING TO TALK A
LITTLE BIT MORE ABOUT IDEOLOGY
GOING FORWARD, BECAUSE THERE ARE
CERTAIN THINGS THAT YOU CAN DO
YOU CAN TRY TO HARDEN THEM.
WHAT WE REALLY HAVE TO DO IS
DEAL WITH THE GENERATIONAL WAR
THAT WE ARE IN.
AND THE OTHER THING
PRESIDENT TRUMP POINTS OUT, NOT
HEARD HIM TALK ABOUT THE DEATH
PENALTY BEFORE.
THERE WAS NO OTHER CASUALTY
HERE.
THIS INDIVIDUAL GETTING HIMSELF
INJURED, TO CALL FOR THE
POSSIBILITY OF THE DEATH PENALTY
IN A CASE LIKE THAT -- THAT IS
CERTAINLY DIFFERENT.
AND I DON'T KNOW IF HE IS GOING
TO PUSH FORWARD ON THAT.
BUT IT IS SOMETHING THAT MIGHT
BE MORE OF A DETERRENT GOING
FORWARD.
>> Jesse: I HAD NOT HEARD OF
COORDINATED ATTACKS RIGHT AFTER
9/11 AND OBVIOUSLY 9/11, AND WE
WOLVES, BUT ISIS INSPIRED
INDIVIDUALS.
THOSE ARE VERY HARD TO PREVENT.
>> Greg: WELL, YOU CANNOT
DO -- THIS IS THE BEST THAT YOU
CAN HOPE FOR WHEN A MURDEROUS
BUTTER D BAG HAS HIS OWN PLAN TO
BLOW UP HIS ASS.
IT IS INTERESTING HOW ISIS IS
HE IS NOT OURS.
PART, BUT THE UNFUNNY PART IS
THE MAYOR SAYS THANK GOD THAT IF
THE ONLY REASON WHY THEY DID NOT
DIE, WAS A FAILURE IN
EXPLOSIVES.
THE INTENT IS THE SAME.
IT IS THE OUTCOME, IT IS NOT
DIVINE INTERVENTION.
IT IS THE FACT THAT THE GUY WAS
NEVER GOOD AT IT.
IT SHOULD NOT MAKE YOU FEEL
GOOD.
THAT MEANS WE DID NOT STOP IT.
HE STILL COULD HAVE DONE IT.
WE SHOULD BE HAPPY THAT NO ONE
DIED.
THAT'S GREAT, BUT WHAT HAPPENS
EFFECT, BECAUSE WE DO NOT -- WE
IMMEDIATELY GO ON TO DO
SOMETHING ELSE.
WE DO NOT THINK ABOUT IT.
WHEN ACTUALLY, IT WAS LUCKY.
>> Kimberly: FALSE SENSE OF
SECURITY IS WHAT IT PRODUCES.
FORWARD AND PREVENTING THINGS
LIKE THAT FROM HAPPENING?
>> Juan: UNLIKE A GREG, I SAY
THANK GOD.
>> Greg: IS THAT IT IS GOOD,
>> Juan: I'M JUST GRATEFUL
THAT REALLY -- WE ARE TALKING
ABOUT MINOR INJURIES EXCEPT FOR
THE GUY WHO APPARENTLY DAMAGED
HIMSELF, HIS HANDS AND HIS
ABDOMEN.
WHAT I NOTICED IN THESE
SITUATIONS, NO CONTACT WITH
ISIS, EVEN THOUGH APPARENTLY HE
WAS ISIS INSPIRED.
SIMILARLY, WHEN I THINK BACK TO
THE GUY WHO RAN HIS TRUCK DOWN
THE BIKE PATH HERE IN LATE
OCTOBER, AGAIN, NO DIRECT
CONTACT OR COORDINATION, BUT
ISIS INSPIRED.
EVEN AS WE CAN DEFEAT ISIS, WHAT
A CANCER.
OUT THERE, AND ESPECIALLY ON THE
INTERNET.
AND THIS GUY IS 27.
I DISAGREE STRONGLY WITH
PRESIDENT TRUMP.
I THINK THAT FAMILY UNIFICATION
IS REALLY GREAT FOR AMERICA.
I THINK THAT FAMILIES ARE SO
>> Greg: PRECISELY.
CHAIN MIGRATION IS OKAY ONE WAY,
IT SHOULD BE OKAY BOTH WAYS.
IF THEY ARRIVE IN A CHAIN AND
ONE PERSON IN THAT CHAIN DOES
SOMETHING, LEAVE IN THE CHAIN.
THE POTENTIAL FOR LEAVING IN THE
CHAIN MIGHT COST THE FAMILY TO
PAY MORE ATTENTION TO THE
ODDBALL IN THE FAMILY.
>> Juan: IT IS JUST THE WAY
THAT UNIONS GAVE OUT CARDS.
IF YOU ARE SOMEBODY'S COUSIN OR
BROTHER OR SON, YOU ARE LIKELY
OTHER PERSON, THE SENIOR PERSON
IS GOING TO BE WATCHING YOU.
YOU DON'T NEED A BOSS, SOMEBODY
IS GOING TO SAY TO YOU, YOU
BETTER ACT RIGHT, YOU ARE
REPRESENTING THE UNION.
>> Greg: ARE YOU COMPARING
UNIONS TO TERRORISTS?
[LAUGHTER]
>> Juan: WHEN I AM SEEING,
THIS IS ONE GUY 27 YEARS OLD,
THE MOTIVE IS WE UNDERSTAND, HE
SAID SOMETHING TO THE EFFECT OF
THE UNITED STATES IS BOMBING MY
COUNTRY, AND I THINK I SHOULD DO
SOME DAMAGE HERE.
HOW RIDICULOUS IS THIS?
>> Jesse: NO ONE IS BOMBING
BANGLADESH.
>> Juan: THAT'S EXACTLY WHAT I
SAID.
NOBODY IS BOMBING BANGLADESH.
I'M GLAD YOU SAID THAT, JESSE,
BECAUSE IT WAS LIKE A PUZZLE TO
ME.
IS SOMETHING GOING ON THAT I
HAVE NOT HEARD ABOUT?
>> Jesse: TECHNICALLY HE IS
INCOMPETENT AND THEN
PHILOSOPHICALLY HE IS
INCOMPETENT AS WELL.
CHAIN MIGRATION.
ARE NOT UNIFIED WHEN THEY COME
OVER HERE.
KIMBERLY, I THINK THE PRESIDENT
WANTS TO HAVE AN IMMIGRATION
SYSTEM BASED ON MERIT.
ARE WITH THEIR HANDS, HOW SMART
IF YOUR UNCLE KNOW SOMEBODY.
>> Kimberly: MAKE IT MORE OF A
VETTED IN TERMS OF WHAT
CONTRIBUTION CAN YOU PROVIDE TO
THIS COUNTRY.
WE HAVE A LOT TO OFFER YOU.
AND WITHOUT, THOROUGH VETTING.
I'M ALL FOR IT.
WHEN YOU SEE A SITUATION LIKE
THIS TODAY.
IT STRENGTHENS THE ARGUMENT OF
THE PRESIDENT.
YOU SEE WHAT HE HAS HAD ENOUGH,
LIKE DANA SAID, HE WENT ON A
VERY FAR A LIMB TO SAY THAT THIS
COULD BE A DEATH PENALTY OFFENSE
DESPITE THAT THERE WAS NOT AN
ACTUAL LOSS OF LIFE.
>> Dana: THAT IS ONE OF THE
THINGS THAT HE DOES IN A
STATEMENT LIKE THIS, HE WILL
THROW THAT CHUM OUT THERE IN THE
WATER, WHERE SOME OF US ARE
LIKE -- OH, I CAN SEE THAT.
AND THAT WILL BE MUCH MORE ABOUT
PRESIDENT TRUMP CALLING FOR THE
>> Juan: THE POINT THAT I
WANTED TO MAKE EARLIER, WITH
REGARDS TO CHAIN MIGRATION, THIS
HERE AND THEN GOT THIS IDEA IN
HIS HEAD.
>> Juan: I WAS GOING TO MAKE
THAT POINT.
THAT SO MANY OF THE PEOPLE WHO
PERPETRATE THIS HORRIFIC,
HORRIBLE ACTS, ARE AMERICANS WHO
HAVE GOTTEN THE IDEAS OVER THE
YEARS.
>> Jesse: IT IS VERY HARD TO
PINPOINT EXACTLY --
>> Kimberly: WE DO NOT HAVE
LIFE TO SEE AT WHAT POINT HE HAD
CONTACT AND AT WHAT POINT HE
BECAME RADICALIZED.
SOME OF IT ON THE INTERNET, BUT
WE DON'T KNOW WHO HE HAS BEEN IN
CONTACT WITH.
>> Jesse: WE WILL PROBABLY
>> Greg: THIS IS THE UNSUNG
INANIMATE HERO, SURVEILLANCE.
WE KNOW A LOT, WE SAW IT.
YOU NEED MORE CAMERAS.
IT'S THE ONLY WAY TO KEEP
FREEDOM, MORE SECURITY.
PEOPLE HATE THIS.
>> Kimberly: >> Dana:
>> Kimberly: >> DanaC
>> Kimberly: >> DanaN
>> Kimberly: >> DanaR
>> Kimberly: >> DanaS
>> Kimberly: >> Dana
>> Kimberly: >> DanaI
>> Kimberly: >> DanaL
>> Kimberly: >> DanaT
>> Kimberly: >> DanaK
>> Kimberly: >> DanaE
>> Kimberly: >> DanaU
>> Kimberly: >> DanaP